if freestyling salsa lyrics taught me
anything it's that I need to brush up on
my eighth grade Spanish so I visited a
teacher who could help me speak like a
native
u.s. boy being you stare muy bien muchas
gracias para su ayuda de nada yo me
llamo Yolanda como usted se llaman may
say llamo conan no no pero lo dijo man
la cámara cigarro con erre see god oh no
Senor en recommend a cigar Oh canary
cigar Oh
amigo and the community Yahoo air a
canary cigar Oh
we have to take off one article code
[Applause]
cerveza composite' say I am America's
biggest star yo soy el mejor actor de
Estados Unidos the America see and how
do I say
don't check on that what some slang that
would help me here
you are convincing someone of something
and and that prison disagree with you
and then you say it's your problem is -
male teen SS to manatee humanity
normality well I just do my this is to
manatee no two martinis
that's your suitcase that's your
suitcase yes that's what you say when
you want to blow someone off humanity
aha Esther Martinez your suitcase friend
what kind of saying is that another
tongue teacher is Priestess tigress
princess three space these three sad
Tigers haha praised three space tigress
forming Presti cestus of the trio
comment our extreme race coming trace
please their free space stars of the
TiVo Garza mother week mugs my three sad
Tigers eat three said month mugs of week
yes but it doesn't make sense boxes and
our country our tongue twisters at least
makes sense
Sally did sell seashells by the seashore
[Applause]
why not no you must have tongue twisters
that make sense why are they eating bugs
full of wheat because they were hog we
but why are they sad then they wouldn't
be sad if they're getting a mug full of
wheat that's good appearance I guess no
seriously it doesn't make sense that's
holding a nation speak to me that way
yes you stand up to me the greatest star
in America I'm Ryan Gosling yes I'm the
most handsome movie star in America gaze
into my ojos is it eyes or is it eggs
while I'm in Cuba there are probably
several phrases I'm going to need to
know that are special to me okoma CDs
say hello I am lost and badly in need of
ain't meant how do you say for my bottom
but a me F&B you for do you know so
laughs it's very it reoccurs you don't
know what it is it's not eczema how
about this one I'm not gay I'm just on
vacation how about this one hello I am
new to Havana and I would like to get my
Froyo on Froyo I want to get my Froyo my
Froyo
Sakiko we for you Froyo oh you like this
I gotta get my Froyo with an enemy Froy
oh no not for you Froyo Froyo this
student has become the teacher
I need to get my Froyo on if you do this
see no one this is really big in the US
right now okay okay how about this
phrase does this freckle look
precancerous to you I just want to learn
the phrase but you really think that
looks bad because I think it low that
you know it's it's dark around the ridge
we need to get some Froyo buzz for
Yolanda
[Applause]